hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in book four of saint augustine's
confessions one of the
topics to which he devotes a number of
chapters is the death of a close friend
and the grief that he feels over it and
he is doing some biographical narration
this is what happened this is what i
felt but it's also a
very deep and probing meditation
on the nature of love friendship grief
what would actually help to deal with
these matters and a connection to god
that he's offering to us the reader and
he's also monologuing with god about he
is reflecting on his own life and we've
got an older augustine looking back at
younger augustine trying to figure
these things out on his own and not
actually having all of the
resources or insights or ideas that
he would need in order to make sense of
this so
the story runs along these lines this is
in chapter four he says
during those years when i first began to
teach it was in the town in which i was
born i gained a friend
my equal in age
flowering like me with youth very dear
to me because of community
of interests and now i want to pause
here for a moment and say that one of
the things that is going on in this set
of chapters
augustine is taking what by that time
are sort of
already traditional and accepted notions
of the best kind of friendship that go
all the way back to aristotle and
perhaps be beyond so you know we're
talking about centuries of accumulated
ideas uh about friendship and he is
saying
these by themselves are not enough so
there's a community of interests shared
interests they're of the same age in
life they're living together he says in
childhood he was not such a friend as he
became later on
but i knew him from that time and so we
spent all sorts of time together i of
course screwed up by taking him away
from the true faith that is christianity
towards the manichaeism that augustine
was was
captivated by
at the time and he says but it was sweet
to us made fast as it was by our ardor
in like pursuits and so this is a really
important part of a traditional
understanding of friendship later on he
will invoke this metaphor that often
gets used for this this great kind of
friendship of the soul
into bodies this is in chapter 6
he says that
i marveled that other men should live
because he whom i loved as if he would
never die was dead i marveled more
that i
his second self
could live when he was dead
well has someone said of his friend that
he is half of his soul for i thought
that my soul and his soul were but one
soul into
bodies therefore
my life was a horror to me because i
would not live as but a
half and this you know two souls and one
bodies goes all the way back to plato's
symposium
you know aristotle references it in the
nick of mccain ethics discussion of
friendship this is a commonplace by that
time and it corresponds to a kind of
feeling that we have when we have a very
deep abiding close love relationship
with another person that we are really
two parts
of a greater whole we are one soul and
two bodies they are our other half and
so
that's part of this as well now
is this true friendship
here's where augustine is kind of adding
something to the picture
no
it's not friendship in the truest sense
it is
you know true like friendship you could
say but what is actually
needed
god
so he tells us
that a friendship cannot be true unless
you
join it together among those who
cleave
to one another and the word for that is
which is coming from this
latin word uh verb
which uh means to like cling to to be
connected with to
grip on to and
he goes on and he says those who are
cleaving to one another they have to do
so by the
charity karitas
right karitate in this
charity is not simply
giving alms to people who need it it is
the word for
a great kind of love and where does this
love come from
here he quotes scripture and he says
poured forth in our hearts by the holy
spirit who is given to us so without
that
charity there's always something missing
to friendship that is what really brings
it together and so we have to love
you could say in and through god or else
it's not going to be a true friendship
this is something different than a lot
of other ancient views on on friendship
what happens well his friend gets sick
with a fever
and looks like he's going to die
already augustine is getting prepared
for this they baptize the friend the
christian
relatives augustine thinks eh who cares
you know uh not not a big deal and then
the friend revives and the friend is
told that he's been baptized and he and
augustine have a kind of confrontation
you could say
he says i tried to make jokes with him
just as though he would joke with me
about that baptism
he had learned that he had received it
he was horrified at me as if i were an
enemy and he warned me with a swift and
admirable freedom if i wish to remain
his friend i must stop saying such
things to him what what things
manichaean things right
augustine was struck dumb and disturbed
but concealed his feelings he's thinking
ah this will blow over
and then the friend gets sicker
and dies
and now the grief comes now the sorrow
and this is you know proportionate to
the love that one feels
this is heart-wrenching sorrow right if
augustine had not made himself
vulnerable you could say by loving
trusting
engaging so deeply with a friend he
could not be
so hurt and he says my heart was made
dark by
sorrow
dolores tenebrothem literally shadows
shades right and
so the sorrow itself makes everything
darker he says that
everything i looked upon was death
my native place was a torment to me my
father's house a strange
unhappiness whatever i had done together
with him my friend was a
cruel torture apart by him my eyes
sought for him
on every side and he was not given to
them i hated
all things because they no longer
held them and so the absence of the love
friend and the presence of everything
else everything else that in some
respect you know augustine that doesn't
deserve to be why does he have to die
instead of all these other poor slobs
over here this is my friend
well this is something that we
can
encounter and experience when we feel
deep grief the world becomes a different
world to the person who is
grieving and this is a
big big problem
augustine finds himself caught within a
we might say emotional or psychological
and even volitional dynamic where he's
befuddled
and
he he talks about this uh in chapter six
he says
i wept bitterly
i
found rest
in my bitterness so wretched was i that
i held the life of wretchedness or
misery miseria in latin uh being unhappy
so so miserable was i that i found the
life of miserable to be more dear
more desirable to me
than my friend himself
so this is really strange isn't it why
would we have a
positive attachment to something so
negative in place of
something positive
this is a strange thing that we human
beings and apparently many other animals
do as well and then he says so there's
there's sort of a conflict in the will
itself
although i wished or willed to change it
to change this situation
yet i was more unwilling i'm choosing
against nolari in latin
to lose it than i was to lose my
friend
and he says i do not know whether i
would have wished its loss even for his
sake
uh as is told of arrestees and pilot ace
two legendary guys who wish to die
together for one another since to them
not to live together was worse than
death but in me
there had arisen i know not what sort of
affection one far different
than theirs
that most heavily weighed upon me both
weariness of life
and fear of dying he doesn't want to die
to rejoin his friend or to like be an
oblivion
no longer having to worry about this
this
affect this
feeling this psychological emotional
dynamic of grieving has become something
he is attached to now
and he raises all sorts of puzzles and
questions about grief and weeping and
the viewpoints that we take a little bit
earlier in
chapter five
as a matter of fact we should we should
bring this up as well augustine he tells
us becomes a great riddle
and the word riddle actually translates
the
latin question a question a question to
himself he doesn't understand himself he
doesn't understand the feelings that
he's having he doesn't understand his
reactions he says i questioned my soul
as to why it was so sad and why it
affected me so grievously and it could
answer me nothing
if i said to my soul hope in god
well that's not helpful he says it did
right not to obey me because
the man
most dear one who she had lost my soul
was more real and more good to her than
the fantasy in which she was made to
hope because at that time
his understanding of god is a fontasia
is a
made-up image he doesn't actually know
god and and this is so often the case
this is a bit of a digression when we go
up to people at funerals and we're like
oh they're in a better place oh god is
helping them you know
we may not know what the hell we're
talking about we may just be mouthing
platitudes and they themselves this may
be totally unconsoling in the same way
as it is for augustine because if they
don't have the right conception of god
how the hell is this going to help
anything emotionally it's not
so he goes on and he says
only weeping was sweet to me why what's
going on with that
and he says
here's some some questions
is it that
you god although present in all places
have flung away our misery far away from
yourself and you abide unchanging
yourself while we spin around in our
trials
that's one way of looking at it you know
god is not bothered by the fact that our
close
loved ones die god is unchanging this is
just something that affects us human
beings there are people who hold that
sort of view
augustine goes on and he says you know
if that was the case then
unless we could weep into your ears no
trace of hope would remain for us
right so that's not a helpful way of
looking at things then he approaches
another possibility
what whence is it then where does this
come from that sweet fruit is plucked
from life's bitterness from mourning and
weeping from sighing and lamentation
why do we come to like this
why do we want to
cry and whine and not do other things
and feel bitter
and see the world darkened by shadows
he goes on and he says does sweetness
lie there because we hope that you'll
graciously hear us god
that holds for our prayers but does that
hold for grief is god
moved by our you know turning into balls
of suffering and tears is that what god
wants from us augustine is asking
and he says
you know
i didn't hope that he would come back to
life nor did i beg for that by my tears
i only sorrowed
and wept for i was wretched and i had
lost my joy
or here's another possibility
is weeping itself a bitter thing
and does it give us pleasure
because of distaste for things in which
we once took joy
but only at such times as we shrink back
from them when we've lost something that
was to us a good and a joy something
that we loved
do we choose bitterness
instead
because we can't bear to
deal with the joy the love that we've
now lost
augustine actually says in the next
chapter uh it's not the time for
questioning but to confess to you god
but he'll go on and you know talk a
little bit more about these
matters as well and we should we should
think about what he says in chapter
seven right he calls this a madness on
his part i raged inside and wept and
became distraught there was for me
neither rest nor reason i carried about
my pierced and bloodied soul rebellious
that being carried by me i could find no
place to put it down
uh not in pleasant groves
we're going to come back to this in a
moment let's think about that you're
you're in a situation where you feel bad
and you can't get away from it
so
what can we in fact
do
right well we're going to talk about
remedies but there is an insight that
augustine expresses and this is in
chapter
six he he tells us
that um
one thing that we don't understand
is that every soul that is bound fast by
friendship
for mortal things
is
wretched whether it realizes it or not
it's you could say potentially wretched
the wretchedness is just around the
corner the misery the the
hurt the grief
why
because those things can be lost as he
goes on to say
it is miserable
and it's torn asunder when it loses them
and then first feels the misery by which
it is wretched even before it loses
these things so we could say you're
you're miserable but you don't know it
you actually think you're feeling good
actually you're feeling great you've got
this friend that you're loving with two
souls in one body and then it's gone
they're good the life that you had is
gone
like all mortal things like all
created
goods it can be taken
from us
so every what is the corollary to this
should we just like withdraw from
everything no no we we should love
things
in the right ways and he's not going to
tell us quite what that is yet
now can we fix this can we find things
to fill in that gap that hole inside of
us he he tries to do that he says i
didn't find uh
peace and happiness in pleasant groves
or in games and singing or in sweet
scented spots or rich banquets
not in the pleasures of the bed chamber
so he's having sex with his concubine
already right not in books and poetry to
define rest all things grew
loathsome
even the light itself
whatever was not he my friend was base
and weary some to me all except
groans and tears for in them alone has
found a little
rest so all these
compensations all these pleasant things
that we could use to distract ourselves
from the the bad feelings that we're
feeling they don't really work not in a
case like this
what does work is feeling the feelings
but that still feels bad right so you
get a little bit of stuff from that what
could
in fact
help
he says
to you o lord my soul should have been
lifted up to be eased by you i knew it
this is interesting i knew it but i
willed it not it's possible for us to
know in a cognitive sense what we ought
to do and yet in a practical affective
sense a volitional sense not to actually
do it
and he says i willed it not
nor was i able to will it why
because
for me when i thought on you you were
not something solid and firm
you were not
then what you are now
you were just an empty phantom and error
was my gut so when we have all sorts of
you could call them wishful thinking
ideas about god
and
you know imaginary things
augustine is perfectly happy to say if
your idea is of god is like the cartoon
guy in the sky that ain't going to cut
it that's not going to help you out at
all
you can only
place these things through a relation to
a god that you actually do know
a real god
lacking that as augustine says having
erroneous conceptions
that's not going to help
what else can help
obviously if augustine
had to have a correct relationship to
god
you know both intellectually and
volitionally in order to get out of his
sorrow and that was the only way that he
could do it
he would still be in his sorrow you know
a good ways into the book
well another thing that can help you out
is time we've got this time heals all
wounds that's kind of a bs thing to say
especially to people who are grieving
but there is something to that he says
time does not take time off nor does it
turn without purpose through our senses
it works wondrous effects in our mind
see how it came and went from day to day
and by coming and going it planted in me
other hopes and other memories and
little by little they filled me up again
with my former
sources of delight my sorrow gave way to
them
but
to it succeeded not new sorrows but yet
causes of new sorrows and so you know
he's he's talking about eventually
being caught up in other matters you
know you lose your spouse and for a year
it's really bad and then you find that
you
you know want to tend to the garden that
both of you worked on together because
it's now the new season and time for
planting and you get you know caught up
in weeding and things like that and
eventually
the sorrow doesn't necessarily ever go
completely away
but it doesn't have the same
totalitarian grasp over you as a person
that it did before it shares that space
with other things and it can emerge
again
later on
um you know my father died when i was
only 11. i still grieve him to today but
it's only once in a while it's not like
the grief that i didn't actually allow
myself to feel then and then had to work
through in my teenage years and 20s
augustine is telling us that time
it's not that time itself heals all
wounds it's what time is filled by that
allows us to have new
new memories to latch onto and new
things to pay attention to so this is a
set of very profound meditations spurred
by the death of a friend
about death and grieving and loss much
more
generally
you